Hello 大家好，欢迎来到阿尔法城，我是黛玉。
最近应该有不少人和我一样被剧版的哈利波特的预告片刷屏了。
作为一个哈密，我只能说非常迫不及待。
今天我们就来讲一个轻松也好玩一点的内容，就是哈利波特中的建筑。
其实我想从这期开始就可以慢慢的做一个新的系列，就叫做影视作品中的建筑与空间。
这一期的哈利波特其实就算是这个系列的第二篇了。
第一篇就是我们阿尔法城第一期讲过的杀修中的建筑。
如果你对这个话题感兴趣的话也可以回头去听一下。
我个人其实是非常喜欢哈利波特这部作品。
我一直觉得它远远不仅是一本儿童文学读，这么简单。
它真正让我特别着迷的其实并不完全是所谓的儿童成长冒险故事本身。
而是它背后的一套世界观的设定。
我觉得这也是哈利波特非常厉害的地方之一，就是他把这个世界做得非常的具体。
从衣食住行到学校的制度、魔法、教育、无私社会。
他都在向我们暗示说这个魔法世界它有自己的生活方式是具体而且丰富的。
所以读到后来就会产生一种非常奇妙的感觉，就是你虽然知道这个魔法世界是虚构的，
但是你总是觉得它好像真的存在一样。
这也是一个伟大的文学作品非常重要的特点，就是这个世界它并不会随着故事的结束而结束，
而是会不断产生新的东西、新的内涵。
比如说中国的伟大的文学作品《红龙梦》后来就形成了我们所说的红雪。
有人研究《红龙梦》里的饮食和糕点，有人研究大官员的建筑，有人研究其中的服饰、家具甚至人物的日常生活。
其实哈利波特也是一样的，围绕这套作品可以不断衍生出各式各样的内容。
我甚至看到过一些国外的出版物，专门教你怎么制作哈利波特里的饮食甜点，或者怎么制哈利波特里的毛衣。
那这个其实就说明一个事情就是当一个虚构的世界它足够完整和丰富的时候，
人们就会开始主动地去补全它，去进入它。
所以这一期我们就从建筑的角度进入这个世界。
当然这里也会存在一个很有意思的问题，就是我们今天讨论的哈利波特中的建筑到底应该以什么作为依据。
因为如果严格来说呢，在作者JK罗林的远著中的建筑描写，其实并没有电影里展现的那么详尽。
那虽然罗林会告诉我们这个霍格沃茨有塔罗有城堡，有礼堂有地下教室，
但是它并没有真的非常丰富的描写这些建筑，也没有为我们画出一套完整的建筑图纸和地图。
但是哈利波特电影其实做了更多，它进行了大量的再创作。
所以今天我们的讨论其实是想把这两部分结合起来，一部分是来自于援助中的文字描述，
那另一部分就来自于电影所建立起来的一个视觉世界。
那本期的内容还是分为三个部分。
第一部分我们会讨论一个世界观的问题，就是如何让一个世界具有魔法感。
第二部分我们想看看霍格沃茨也就是这个魔法学校它本身的一个空间圆形。
它其实本来是想做一个全部的解读，但是后来发现内容实在是太多，
所以我们就这一期就先主要围绕哈利波特中最主要的建筑学校做一个梳理。
那第三部分我们来看看电影的拍摄过程中它所取景的空间具体都是哪里？
那为什么会选择在那里拍摄？那我们就开始吧。
那首先哈利波特之所以为什么那么吸引我们？
很大程度上它是一个依托于现实世界展开的故事。
它并不是一个纯粹的非常架空的设定。
所以在罗林笔下的这个时空关的设定呢，
它同时平行存在这两个世界，一个是现实世界，
也就是我们所在的这个麻瓜世界，我们都是麻瓜世界里的人，
所以就非常带入感。那另一个就是魔法世界，也就是巫师的世界。
那魔法世界对现实世界其实是隐藏起来的。
当然隐藏魔法世界它其实也是有一个原起的，
就是在1869年生效的这个叫国际巫师联合会保密法，
它是用作保护巫师世界并不被麻瓜人士发现，
从而确保巫师世界的安全和魔法世界的稳定的这样一个立法。
那为什么要保密呢？它其实也是有一个历史的起源，
就是巫师和麻瓜之间非常紧张的关系。
那在中世纪时期呢，麻瓜也就是这些不会魔法的人，
它因为恐惧魔法而破坏巫师，导致巫师不得不东躲西瞧。
那为了保护自射安全，巫师们就会决定要隐藏魔法，
所以这个国际巫师联合会保密法就应运而生。
有了这样一个法律的设定，那么接下来的问题就是，
那如何安置这两个世界的交界处合入口？
罗林就有一个很有趣的设定，就是魔法世界的入口都是隐藏在。
现实世界的缝隙之中隐藏在那些无人在意的角落里。
那么咱们就稍微盘点一下两个世界交汇地方在哪里？
第一个就是最有名的，大家第一个想到的就是九尤四分之三站台，对吧？
在英国的国王世子车站中，从第九站台和第十站台之间的柱子穿过去。
Excuse me, sir, can you tell me where I might find platform nine and three quarters?。
Nine and three quarters, I think they're being funny, do you?。
Every year packed with muggles, of course.。
Come on, platform nine and three quarters this way.。
这个设定就很妙，它并不是有一个专门的魔法火车站，
甚至也没有多加出来一个魔法站台，
而是就用了现实世界中存在的这个国王世子车站，
然后把它设定为两个站台之间的柱子里面。
第二个入口呢，就是破浮酒吧，
原文中说它是一个骯髒的狭小酒吧，
路过的人根本不会看它一眼，
只会看到左边的一家大书店和另外一边的一家唱片店。
如何从破浮酒吧进到魔法世界，
就需要在酒吧里头的小天井里敲特定的砖，
然后这个砖就能移动出一条通道，通向对角像，
就是小巫师们购物的地方。
那另一个呢，是魔法部的入口，
也就是这个魔法社会当中的公园，他们上班的地方，
那这上班的路径呢，在原住当中，
罗林告诉我们的两种，
第一种方式是通过电话亭，
就是在伦敦市中心的一条七两的小街道上，
有一个破浮酒的红色电话亭，
然后拨打62442这个号码，
你就能连接到魔法部的入口。
这里就有一个小彩蛋，62442是什么含义，
这里可以给一个暗示，
大家可以试着用九宫阁书法打一下这个号码，
也许会有惊喜。
那么魔法部还有第二种进入的方法，
就是在第七部的这个死亡生气里面，
哈里罗恩和赫米，他们三个喝了复方汤剂，
来伪装成魔法部的三个工作人员，
在地下公共厕所的小隔间里呢，
通过冲睡马桶的方式把自己冲进魔法部，
好像这种上班方式也并不是特别体面。
那原住中还有一个入口是圣盲哥魔法商兵医院的入口，
就是一个停业装修了十几年的一个百货商店，
然后你和厨窗当中的人说你要去看望谁，
他就通过玻璃门让你进去了。
那大家有没有发现这些空间都有一个共同点，
就是他的入口非常狭小，非常隐蔽，
甚至是有点肮脏和惨迫的状态，
但是当你通过之后呢，
一个非常灰红壮丽的一个魔法世界，
就像舞台木布一般拉开了。
如果说我们跟随着哈里的角度啊，
一个一直生活在麻瓜世界里的小孩，
通过他的眼睛进入魔法世界的这个过程，
那本身就会感觉有非常强烈的，
这种反转和精一的成分。
那除了正常世界和魔法世界之间的入口之外呢，
那在真正的魔法世界当中，
建筑空间是如何表达魔法感的，
就是如果你是导演，你想要表达一个具有魔法的房子，
那你想要通过什么样的语言来表达呢？
电影中给了我们一个答案，
就是说并不是完全用我们不熟知的一种建筑言，
只是用了脱胎于现实世界，
用那些早已存在的建筑空间和语言，
但是要对他们进行一种魔法化的改造或者变体。
那么这种魔法化的改造是什么呢？
我总结了几种方式啊，
第一种就是把它变成能动的，
让这个死的建筑仿佛有生命，仿佛活了过来。
比如说霍格沃茨里面这个活动来活动去的这个大楼梯，
还有大理堂的这个天花板，
它被施了魔法之后能够反映出天空的样子，
可以变成星空，变成雾云，变成暴风雨等等。
再比如说有求不应屋，
只有当你特别需要它的时候，你才能够进入这个房间。
包括还有这个肖像化的人，
首先他们是可以动，
再一个就是他们可以在不同的肖像化之间串门，
就是肖像化自己可以联系成一个并行于真实世界的一个魔法网络。
这个是第一点变成能动。
那第二个呢，就是变成迷宫，
而且有重重的机关，这个就很好理解。
就比如说哈里通过这个维斯爱卵生兄弟继承给他的这个火点地图，
看到可以从霍格沃茨去这个霍格莫德村的七条通道，
有的是要通过点一下这个女巫说左右分离，
然后才能够让出一条路来。
那最近点的一个有机关感觉的空间呢，
就是这个四个学院，
它每个学院的宿舍楼的入口，
那这些入口都不是像我们现代的学校中的宿舍，
它会有一个大大的知识标，写着宿舍对吧，
而是藏在画像后面，藏在一堆南瓜之中，
它都是隐藏起来，必须通过口令或者答题的方式，
就像一密码锁，然后能够进到这个休息室。
所以大家还记得小说一开始，
他们作为一年级的新生，第一天入学，
需要急涨带他们走回这个宿舍的路，
不然其实自己是找不到的。
这种经验呢，就和我们现代社会中对于一个建筑的要求正好相反。
现代公共建筑中需要的是清晰，高校和透明，
就恨不得所有的地方都要有指示系统，
告诉你怎么走，这个是什么漏，那个是什么漏。
但是霍格莫德村其实正好相反，
它是一个非常复杂，隐秘，甚至还能变来变去的一个巨大迷宮。
所以你会发现霍格莫茨的很多空间都是隐藏起来的，
需要一些机关来激活，
就比如说邓布利多的校长办公室的入口，
就是一个巨大的一个石头怪兽，
然后你要说一个口令之后呢，
这个怪兽会跳到一边，
它身后的墙才会列成两半，
出现了一个像自动服梯一样的旋转楼梯，
把你的人带上去，
才能够来到邓布利多办公室的门前。
再举一个例子，就是霍格莫茨的厨房入口，
一开始大家都不知道厨房在哪里，
然后后来哈里他们发现，
它是在一幅画着一碗水果的画后面，
然后你要挠一下这个画里面的梨子，
然后它这个梨子它又会铺齿一声笑出来，
变成一个非常大的一个绿色的门把手，
把这个门，绿色的门把手推开，
才能进到厨房里。
就是这些设定都是非常细节，
而且是非常有一种解迷的一种趣味感。
那我们梳理过了这个魔法世界，
它是一个和现实世界并行的世界，
而且它有隐藏起来，
然后甚至魔法世界本身的建筑，
它也有许多重重的机关，
重重的隐蔽。
那接下来的第二部分呢，
我们就要看看这个真正的霍格莫茨，
这所魔法学校，
它的一个形式来源，
也就是霍格莫茨这所学校的原型。
我们先说结论啊，
霍格莫茨的学校原型呢，
我总结了一下，
其实是三种欧洲中世纪的空间的杂柔体，
这三种分别是什么呢？
第一个就是修道院，
第二个是城堡，
第三个是技术制学校。
所以霍格莫茨其实是杂柔了这三种原型，
种的很多特点。
那么具体我们就来看看这三种原型是什么，
它的历史是什么，
它的哪些特点能够被应用到霍格莫茨这个魔法学校当中去的，
然后它的这些特点又跟魔法世界产生什么关系。
那首先我们来讲讲修道院，
修道院的原型呢，起源于埃及，
就是当时僧侣们为了灵魂的修行，
离开城市，去茅屋或者山洞里面隐居，
听起来是不是很像中国的修行的隐士啊，
但是中国在山中修行的隐士和欧洲的修道院的修事不同的是呢，
中国的隐士大多数都是离群所居，
就是一个人生活，
但是欧洲的基督教隐士啊，
他最后主见是过上了一种集体生活，
就是大家一起在一个远离城市的地方，
这个有点像佛家的僧人，
就是一起在寺庙里居住修行对吧。
那么这个集体生活的空间它长成什么样子呢，
大家可以记住一个特征，
就是我总结了八个字，
叫做微型城市内向包围，
那微型城市的意思显而易见，
就是它像一个小的城市一样自己自足，
它有一套完整生活链，
可以足不出户的那种。
那么内向包围呢，
就是它的空间有点像一个洋葱，
最核心的是在中间，
然后四周一圈都是附属的功能空间，
这个就导致了它并没有一个强烈的仪式序列，
那这也很好理解，
因为修道院的核心功能是修道对吧，
它是僧人的居所，
它并不负责来吸引教中，
而这点上就和我们中国的佛家寺庙有所区别，
就是佛寺还是非常需要相伙的，
所以它需要一个和外界相勾脸的一个序列路线，
就是上台阶上山门，
然后是中楼、古楼、大熊宝殿、观景殿等等，
但对于基督教来说呢，
它吸引教众、吸引相伙，
主要上那些在城市中的大教堂，
而在乡野中的修道院呢，
它就是一个单纯的僧侣居住功能，
所以在修道院的平面中很容易出现这种情况，
就是当你进入到修道院的时候，
你可能要先穿过一些伸口棚、仰卷，
然后才能到达核心的会郎和教堂区域。
那么一个理想的修道院都有哪些必要的空间类型呢？
我们从核心说到附属空间，
首先第一个核心空间肯定是教堂，
我们刚刚说过修道院的教堂是给僧人用的，
不是给大众不到的一个场所，
所以空间上呢，就会倾向于分割成一些小小的空间，
用于修世之间的一些小规模的机会，
那这个是修道院教堂一个特点。
那么第二个也就是我觉得最重要的空间类型，
也是我们今天主要要讲的类型，就叫回郎。
这个空间是哈里波特系列电影中，
许多故事和剧情所发生的地方。
在哈里波特的电影版本中呢，
有许多经典的场景都是在回郎这个空间类型中拍摄的，
比如说圣诞节下大学的时候，
小哈里手臂上坐着海德威，
然后走到回郎的庭园中心放飞海德威，
在比如说密室里面这个基尼在墙上写血字，
然后写这个密室被打开了的那个场景，
也是发生在回郎中。
还有就是很多拍摄他们下课后，
学生们在走廊聊天打闹的场景，
都是在这个回郎，那什么是回郎呢？
他在英文当中有一个专有名词，
叫做Cloister，他源自于拉丁语的Cloistrom，
意思就是一个封闭的空间，
中文翻译成回郎，
虽然这个翻译并没有把词源中这个封闭的意象翻译出来，
但是他很巧妙地把这个空间的平面特征翻译出来了，
也就是回字形的一拳狼子回郎，
这个回郎中央为何出一个封闭的路天的方形庭院，
然后一般这个庭院中央会放置一个喷泉，
这个狼子朝向中央庭院的一侧全都是开场的拱圈，
拱圈的顶部有拱顶覆盖，
那另一侧就是属于其他建筑的一个实体的箱体，
所以回郎实际上就是连着修道院中各个重要功能空间的一个人行走的一个流线，
有一点点像我们园林中的狼子最初的功能，
把不同的房子连接在一起，
但是随着功能的改变，
回郎后来就逐渐脱离了最开始单纯的一种交通空间，
它承担了更多修士们的日常活动，
比如说在中世纪的时候修士往往在这里冥想，
抄写经文和讨论学书，
它有一点像教室和自习室的功能，
而回郎的位置一般也仅贴着大教堂的南侧墙壁，
我们知道教堂一般都是坐西朝东，
和我们中国寺庙坐北朝南是不同的，
一个坐西朝东的房子它一定会有个南墙，
我们回郎的院子就是为教堂的南侧墙壁，
南侧墙壁有一个好处就是它的光线非常充足，
也非常适宜开展一些日常的活动，
所以我觉得电影中有很多情境选择发生在这个空间中也是非常巧妙的，
就是它承担了学生们从上课的教室到休息的宿舍中间的过渡地段，
这个过渡地段也可以发生很多的自由的活动和敘事。
那我特地查了一下英文的原文，
其实罗林并没有确切的使用Cluster这个词，
也就是并为特质霍格沃斯中有这样的一个空间类型，
但是导演选用这样的空间实际上是非常贴合，
霍格沃斯的学校属性的，
就我们刚刚说霍格沃斯本质上附合了三样东西，
城堡、修道院和学院对吧，
那回廊作为修道院最有特征的空间类型，
那也很符合霍格沃斯中世纪建筑风格的背景。
那我修道院给霍格沃斯提供的第二个空间类型，
就叫公共餐厅Refectory，
也就是霍格沃斯的大立堂，大家一起吃饭的地方，
而这个空间可以说是故事中非常重要的场景。
修道院的这个空间类型为什么重要呢？
就是因为在修道院中，
它第一次把做饭和吃饭这两件事分开了，
我们知道在中世纪的住宅中，
往往餐厅和厨房是合而为一的，
一圈是厨房的各种设备，
中央放一张厂桌，
那大家就围绕这张厂桌吃饭，
那正如我们一直强调的是，
修道院世界上是一群人在一起过一种集体生活，
那这种集体生活是非常制度化的，
那一个东西但凡制度化之后，
就很容易形成分区对吧，
就会出现专门准备饭菜的厨房，
和专门集体一起吃饭的公共餐厅，
而这里就一个比较有意思的事情，
就是霍格沃斯的大立堂除了来源于修道院的公共餐厅之外，
还有一个更重要的空间来源，
就是中世纪的城堡大厅，也叫桂桃。
实际上罗林的原文中，
对霍格沃斯的理堂的用词也是叫做的桂桃，
而不是霍格沃斯Refectory，
所以接下来我们顺着这个大立堂，
来讲讲城堡这种空间类型，
对霍格沃斯建筑的一个影响。
就如果说我们现在提起霍格沃斯，
脑海中最先浮现的一定是一个巨大的威额的城堡，
高高崇利在悬崖之上，
然后它的塔楼灵力，湖水和泉山缓绕，
整个场景非常庄严又神秘，
一座城堡通常会给人一种非常强烈的空间感受，
一个就是防御感，是一个与世格绝的堡垒，
它把外面的世界挡在门外，也把里面的人保护起来。
第二个特征就是它充满了神秘感，
因为它的空间并不是现代以上那种非常清晰和简单的建筑，
它就拥有非常多的空间类型，
地下室，塔楼，礼堂，密室等等，
而且这些空间往往上下交错，彼此隐藏，
如同一个迷宫一般，同时也可以不断地继续生长。
我们会发现这两个特征，
一个是防御，一个是神秘，
它几乎完美地契合了霍格沃斯作为做魔法学校的本质，
更有趣的是，罗林在原著中就明确表示过霍格沃斯是一座城堡，
另外我们从时间线上来看，这个设定也非常准确，
因为城堡这种建筑类型的出现，
大约就是在公元十世纪左右，就是中世纪的中期，在欧洲大量出现。
那根据Portmore官网上的这个设定，
霍格沃斯的建校时间大概是在公元的九九零年，
也就是几乎和城堡这种建筑类型出现的时间是在同一个年代，
说到这里不得不再次感慨，罗林这些细节方面做的实在是太好了。
那么在这里我们就不妨提出一个问题，
就是霍格沃斯为什么必须是一座城堡，
为什么不能是一个别的什么巨型的空间，
比如说一座小城市，或者说像现在的校园一样，
就是在一大片空地上该续续嘟嘟嘟的房子。
那么要回答这个问题，我们就要首先来看看城堡的历史，
城堡这种建筑形态并不是凭空出现的，
大概是在九世纪到十世纪，也就是我们常说的中世纪中期，
西欧经历了长期的政治碎片化和地方权力的兴起，
维京人马扎尔人以及来自南方的袭击，
使得地方领主越来越需要依靠自己的力量保护领地，
于是住宅就开始武装起来，最初城堡的形式其实很简陋的，
就是一个土丘加上一座木塔，周围有一圈柵栏，
但很快人们就会发现石头这个东西比木头的柵栏更加可靠，
位于一个有高度的地方比在平地的地方更有优势，
于是随着时间推移，木头就逐渐被石头所取代了，
塔罗也越来越高，墙体越来越厚，城门也越来越复杂，
才逐渐形成了我们今天想象中的一个中世纪城堡。
所以城堡最原始最核心的功能就是保护里面的人来阻挡外面的人，
这一点放到霍格沃茨上其实也非常契合的，
就是说在最后的霍格沃茨大战中，
这所学校靠着一些学生和数量有限的教授，
也能够成为地狱附地魔和大批师祖徒的一个重要防线，
那我想城堡本身起到了功不可没的作用，
比如说麦格教授用了那个石蹲出洞这个咒语，
让城堡中所有的石像和盔甲都活了过来。
那如果城堡只是一个军事设施的话，
那其实并不能完全解释霍格沃茨为什么会拥有如此丰富的内部空间。
以做真正的中世纪的城堡，
它同时也必须还是领主的居所，
它能提供一个相对完整的一个生活共同体的空间，
不仅有领主和士兵，也有它的家族、
仆人、工匠以及其他的工作人员。
所以一做完整的城堡，
它必须有厨房、有卧室、有储藏空间、有礼拜堂以及有各种后勤设施。
也就是说一做大型的城堡，
实际上已经不只是一栋房子，
而是一个可以相对独立运转的一个小型社区。
那从这个角度看，
它和我们刚刚讲过的修道院其实是有一点类似的，
就是两者都是要把一群人的居住、工作、饮食、礼拜和日常生活，
全都纳在同一个集合的建筑体系之中。
霍格沃茨更是如此了，
它是一座典型的技术职学校，
想要把青春期的一千多个小巫师，
一周、七天、一天、二十四小时都关在一个封闭的区域内，
那这个地方就一定有应有敬有的吧，
大家要非常丰富，有教室、有宿舍、有厨房、有图书馆、有医院、有浴室、有公共休息室等等。
同时它又要有某些防御型，
那么城堡就是一个非常好的一个空间圆形，
它能够把一个魔法世界收容到这样一所巨大的连续的建筑中去。
那城堡的第三个重要属性呢，就是行政。
朱世纪城堡它并不止是一座住宅，而且还是一个领地的政治中心，政府大楼对吧。
领主在这里接待外来的宾客、举行宴会、处理事务、主持司法和各种仪式。
而这些活动往往都会围绕城堡中最重要的公共空间展开，就是大厅。
但是我们现在先不讲这个鬼草这个大厅，
当我们等到讲学院这个空间圆形的时候，我再回来详细说它。
但是至少在城堡的语境中呢，鬼草就是这个大厅，
首先是一个公共生活和权力展示的中心。
霍格沃茨的大礼堂也几乎继承了这种空间角色。
就是大礼堂它不仅仅是一个食堂，它是我们开学举办宴会，
举办分院仪式，举办圣诞舞会，以及日常的一日三餐。
而且他们上了高年级之后学习幻影一行的时候也都在大礼堂内举行。
它和中世纪城堡中的鬼草一样，仅仅是一个吃饭的地方，
而是一个整个学校最重要的一个公共空间。
至于为什么英国学院会把这种大厅发展成为我们所熟悉的Dining Hall，
以及霍格沃茨的礼堂中，
什么四个学院是坐在四个长桌，
然后老师坐在另一端的桌子上这种空间布局，和它的历史远远的，
我们会放到下一小节，技术制学院的这个部分再讲。
所以说我们总结一下，城堡有三种功能，防御，居住和行政。
它和魔法世界中霍格沃茨之所学校所需要的功能是非常契合的。
因此罗林选择城堡这种建筑类型，
作为魔法学校的原型是非常顺理成章的。
这就带来了霍格沃茨空间的几个特征，
这些特征也深深地影响了哈里波特系列故事线的一个发展。
首先第一个特征就是复杂，
就是说一个城堡它一定不是一次建成的，
然后永远不变的东西，当然霍格沃茨也不是。
我们刚刚说霍格沃茨的建校时间是在公园995年，
到了哈里波特的时代已经过去了1000多年，
在这1000多年中，我相信学校的模样应该发生过了很多变化，
有过许多的增补和修改，比如说这一带加了一座塔楼，
下一带又扩展了一个庭院，
因此霍格沃茨就会形成一个弥工班的层层累积的空间结构，
而这种弥工班的空间天然地就符合一个冒险故事的文本特征，
就霍格沃茨中很多空间都是随着三人组的成长，
才会逐渐出现的。比如说在哈里入学的第二年，
它发现了密室，在入学的第五年，
凤凰社的那本书中它才发现了有求币萤屋。
可以说对于一座复杂城堡的探索，
是伴随着哈里这些小巫师们成长的，
所以它不是一个死的固定的一个空间。
同时呢，互国卧室空间不仅仅复杂，
而且它是高度垂直化的。
就是说学生们一会儿是要去地下室的摩耀课，
叫是上snip的摩耀课，一会儿要爬到天文塔上上天文课，
那他们的宿舍甚至都在不同的level上面，
就是斯莱特林的公共休息室是在互国卧室城堡地牢的一个石墙后面，
它是连着水下的，它是在最底层，
而格兰芬多休息室又在城堡七楼的这个塔楼上，
是在顶层。这种不同学院，不同空间特质的设定，
比现代的学校中这种千篇于绿的宿舍楼，
实在是有趣和有魔法感太多了。
现代建筑往往倾向一把相同的功能，
放在一个非常类统的标准化的房间里，
但是城堡不是这样的。
对后国如此来说，高度本身就是空间特征的一个部分，
而空间特征也和不同的学院的理念和性格相符。
所以说，后国此的垂直性是在通过不同的高度，
赋予空间不同的性格。
所以我们最后来总结一下，对于城堡这个圆形呢，
它的防御功能让建筑成为抵抗外部威胁的一个参与者，
它的迷宮般的这个丰富空间呢，
又给学生提供了非常完整的生活体验，
也让建筑永远还有尚未被发现的这个部分。
它的垂直性，也让空间具有非常不同的性格属性。
而这些特点呢，就让后国此之所学校和我们现代意义上的校园如此的不同，
产生了迷人的魔法感，从而让人无限的陷害。
那么，讲完了修道院，讲完了城堡，
我们接下来再看看后国此的这个第三个空间圆形，
就是技术制学校。
当然严格来说呢，技术学校也不能算一种空间圆形啊，
因为后国此本身它确实是一所技术制学校，对吧。
罗林曾经在采访中解释过说，
为什么要把后国此设定成一个技术的学校，
是因为它许多的剧情和场景都要发生在深夜。
如果学生每天傍晚都要回家的话呢，
那哈里就不可能在深夜偷偷的走出宿舍，
然后也不可能探究出那么多的秘密。
所以哈里入学之后很快就得到了隐形斗篷，
某种意义上简直就是为了让它在半夜，
在学校里到处乱逛而准备的。
那我们说回技术制学校，
技术制学校拥有一些非常独特的特征，
它都在这个哈里波特系列的电影中做了充分的展现。
比如说这个house system，就是学院制度，
就是将学生划分不同的house，
然后这个每一个学院都有自己的院长，
再比如说这个学长制度，就是prefect system，
就是高年纪的学生可以管理，
甚至惩罚低年纪的学生。
那么除了这些体系和制度呢，
技术制学校还未后果此提供了一些非常有特点的空间，
比如说这个公共休息室。
男生在桌子上，桌子上，
女生在右边。
你会找到所有的宝贝已经被拥有。
那我们这部分主要想讲讲最有特色的一个空间就是后果子的大力堂。
我们刚刚讲修道院的时候呢，
提到过这个他们吃饭的地方叫Refectory，
就是修道院餐厅，
这样承保的时候呢，也提到过这个大力堂，
是承保中非常重要的一个公共空间，
可以承担宴会借贷仪式和其他的公共活动。
而到了后果子呢，
这些传统就非常巧妙的交織在了一起。
我们先来看看后果子的大力堂长什么样啊，
罗林是这么写的。
哈里从未想到过竟会有如此神奇美妙，
复立堂皇的地方。
其他学生都以分别为座在四张长桌旁，
桌子上成千上万只飘荡在办公的蜡烛照亮力堂，
四张桌上摆着一亿闪光的金盘和高脚酒杯。
礼堂上手的台子上摆着另一张长桌，
那是教师们的席位。
听了荣班漆黑的天花板上闪说着点点星光，
他听见赫米小声的说，
这里是过魔法，
看起来跟外边的天空一样。
那基本上这个描述呢，
在电影中也得到了非常完美的还原。
所以罗林其实描述了非常详细的他们一个做次的方法，
就是许多人坐在长桌上，
首先坐在长桌上吃饭这种做法的起源啊，
很巧也就是起源于中世纪的时期。
最开始大家就是围在一块木板，
这个木板架在一个支架上，
那这个木板有个名字就叫做board，
这也是英文中为什么，
后来由用board来表示这个伙食，
既而有了这个room and board，
就是这个包食素的这个意思。
最后发展出了这个boarding school，
就是我们说的这个技术职学校。
所以其实中文如果逐字翻译的话，
boarding school 字面上意思其实是提供伙食的学校，
这里我们可以插入一个很有趣的一个词源，
的小知识，就是这个board 呢，
最初是指切割得到了一块木板，
这个木板是平的对吧，
在词汇的演变和使用中呢，
它就逐渐延伸出三个核心的词役，
这三个核心词役呢，
都是和这块木板的用法是有关系的。
首先第一个就是大家在这块木板上吃饭，
那后来就延伸出刚刚说的伙食和食素的意思，
那第二个用法呢，就是大家可以围绕这块木板上开会，
讨论问题，把它当做一个会议桌，
这种用法呢，后面就延伸出了董事会和理事会的含义。
那第三个用法就是把这个木板作为登船的甲板，
所以说登上船只的这个动作就叫做boarding，
所以后来又延伸出来乘坐各类的交通工具，
比如说登机就用的是board，登机牌就是boarding pass，对吧，
那这个就是很有趣啊，就是关于此语的源头是一块木板，
然后它的隐身意义是围绕这块木板产生了三种不同的用法，
产生出了三种不同的核心含义。
那么扯远了，是我们再说回Hogels里堂中的这四个厂桌，
就是这四个board。
而最有趣的是呢，里堂中的教师所做的位置啊，
是在四个厂桌空间的尽端，
这个桌子呢，也有专门的词汇，它不叫board了，
它叫高桌high table。
但是高桌的意思啊，并不是说桌子高，
是桌子所在的位置啊，是一个抬高乐的平台，
就是有点像讲台一样的一个抬高的区域。
而同时学生做的长桌呢，和老师做的高桌，
他们用的椅子也是不一样的。
学生的长桌一般就是用的是长凳，
是没有靠背的那种长长的凳子。
但是高桌旁边配的就是正规的椅子，
而且是更具有身份象征的，更正式的那种高背椅。
那这种空间布局的背后啊，
其实是一套非常古老的空间秩序。
就在中世纪的城堡，Grid Hall中啊，
这个高桌上也通常是领主，家族成员和非常重要的客人。
那么其他人就按照身份和地位，
分布在大堂中的这个长桌上。
距离高桌越近，通常就意味着身份越高，
也就是说社会等级直接转换成了一个空间关系。
同时修道院里的这个refactory，就是用的也是长桌，
但是它附于了长桌另外一种意义，
就是修道院里的僧侣，共同生活，共同祈祷，
共同学习，共同进餐的空间。
所以修道院里的长桌的意思是，
大家在同一个时间，同一个空间，
遵循共同的规则进餐。
所以说我们今天看到这种高桌加长桌的这种布局，
那其实正好汇聚了这两种传统，
一边就是城堡的这个大厅所代表的一种等居秩序，
另外一边就是修道院的refactory，
食堂所代表的公共生活。
那这两种传统，
后来又非常巧妙的在英国的学院制度中相遇了，
并且依旧延续至今。
所以英国最有名的一些古老的大学，
比如说牛津剑桥，
他们至今仍就保留着这种布局，
就是高桌位于大厅镜头的高台之上，
学院的院长，
然后资深的研究员和一些贵客会坐在高桌上，
普通的学生啊，
则在大厅的厂桌上用餐，
而且到了今天这些保留学院制度的大学里面，
出席晚宴也会要求学生穿正装，
甚至有的需要在餐前用拉丁纹倒高，
所以这种布局和吃饭方式也直接成为了。
罗林在刻花霍格沃斯大理堂时候的一个形式的来源。
那我们讲到这里就可能有小伙伴问了，
为什么霍格沃斯不像是我们现代校园的食堂一样，
就是我在窗口打饭，
然后在各自的四人或者六人的小桌子上吃饭呢？
那这个是个特别有趣的问题啊，
就是说对于现实的高校来说呢，
其实吃饭这个事情，
真的就是吃饭这件事情本身，
它是个后勤问题。
但是对于霍格沃斯不是这样的，
对于这个霍格沃斯来说，
吃饭是一种仪式，
或者说是一种共同体的仪式。
所以为什么要分四个桌子给四个学院呢？
每当你坐在礼堂里面，
坐在属于自己学院的这个厂桌前吃饭的时候，
你都能非常强烈的意识到，
你是你所属学院的一员。
那四个学院的四个厂桌，
又构成了霍格沃斯之所学校。
所以在这个厂桌上呢，
有一年级的新生，
这些刚进入魔法世界的小朋友，
也有七年级即将离开学校，
不如社会的青年。
而且在这个厂桌上发生的事情，
也不仅仅是吃饭。
早餐的时候，
大家会接受猫头鹰的信件或者包裹，
然后平时学生也会在这里交换信息，
聊天,
然后庆祝节日，
和其他学院相互吵架斗气。
所以这种对于学院的一种归属感，
就是在这样的日常中，
被不断强化的。
所以大家也能理解，
为什么举办三场争霸赛的那个圣诞舞会的时候，
四条厂桌被撤走了，
取而代之的是一百来张点着灯的小圆桌。
而这个不仅仅是一个什么浪漫不浪漫的问题，
这个其实是一个非常精妙的一个空间变化，
就说厂桌意味着共同体，
就是一个学院的学生只能坐在这个学院的场桌上。
但是小圆桌就意味着是独立的个体。
贺奇帕奇的学生可以和拉文克劳的学生约会跳舞，
格兰芬多的学生也可以邀请斯莱特尼学生坐在一起。
那这个时候他们就不再首先代表着自己的学院，
甚至他可以不代表后果似，
而是和其他学校的学生坐在一起。
这个时候学生就会被还原为一个具体的人，
但是非常可惜的是这个，
电影中并没有采用罗林原本的这个一百来张小圆桌的设定，
他还是用了四张巨大的大圆桌，
这个是我觉得从空间上他不够极致的一个地方。
所以我们来总结一下，
霍国词这所学校的三个空间圆形，
首先修道院的圆形呢，
为霍国词提供了某种知识性和共同生活的一种制度感。
它让这所学校成为了一个有着自身秩序，
时间表和集体生活方式的一种知识共同体。
那城堡的这个圆形呢，
则为霍国词提供了防御性和神秘感，
这些高墙塔楼地牢和封闭的边界，
和这些层层叠叠无法被完全看透的空间，
让这所学校始终保持着与现实世界之间的一个距离，
也让它成为一个等待被探索的一个神秘的世界。
最后呢，学院的这个圆形，
或者说是技术至学校的这个圆形呢，
则赋予了霍国词一种非常重要的现实感和制度感。
学生在这里学习住宿，用餐，交友，
按照明确的学院和年纪组织起来，
因此它就不太像一个神秘的宗教组织，
也不像一个只存在于童话中的魔法长所，
而是真正是一所扎扎实实存在的，
能够持续运行的一个学校。
所以呢，修道院，城堡和学院这三种类型，
共同构成了霍国词最重要的空间基础。
它既是一所古老的格局城堡，
又是一个共同生活的修道院，
同时还是一座真正的构让孩子在其中学习和成长的学校。
这三者的叠加让霍国词显得非常神秘，
古老而且不可思议，
但是又非常的具体和真实，
甚至让人产生一种错觉就是它仿佛真的存在于。
苏国兰高地的某个我们上运找到的山谷里。
那我们讲了魔法世界是如何营造魔法感，
讲了霍国词背后的三种空间圆形。
那最后一个部分呢，我们就来看看。
哈里波特系列电影中用了哪些真实世界中的建筑，
我们来盘念一下电影中这个拍摄霍国词城堡的几个曲景地。
那么要说霍国词曲景地呢，
这就不得不提到一种非常重要的建筑风格，
叫做哥特式。
而在电影中呢，无论是霍国词回廊的这个拱券，
大礼堂巨大的花窗，城堡高层的坚定，
还是木质长桥两侧的这个窗框啊，
都透露出非常强烈的哥特气质。
而这些场景的曲景地大部分也都选择了英国的中世纪哥特建筑，
比如说牛津的这个伯德利图书馆，
新学院回廊，
位于伦敦北边的这个格罗斯特大教堂，
和位于达勒姆的达勒姆大教堂等等。
他们呢，都为这些场景注入了属于哥特的神秘感，
和属于中世纪的时间感。
那究竟什么是哥特式呢？
可能大多数人对这个词啊，并不陌生。
比如说哥特风的腐蚀，哥特风的音乐。
但是如果真的让我们说最开始的这个哥特式建筑，
究竟是什么，可能就会卡住了。
那么作为一个建筑科普类的一个伯克，
那今天我们就先用几分钟，先简单认识一下这个哥特到底是什么。
要说哥特这个词呢，
他的词源是属于日漫部落的一个分支，叫做哥特人。
但是这里有个非常有意思的地方就是，
哥特建筑并不是哥特人建造的建筑。
那这个词真正被用来称呼一种建筑风格呢，
已经是哥特人消亡很多年之后的事情了。
那这个词是怎么产生的呢？
是在欧洲的文艺复兴时期这个人文主义者，
他们重新发现这个古希腊古罗马的艺术，
然后把他们视为文明和理性的典范。
但相较之下，他们对于中世纪的建筑并不欣赏，
于是他就借用哥特这个词，就是Gothic，
把他们认为出野野蛮和贝利古殿传统的建筑成为哥特识。
所以这个词最初其实多少带有一点贬义，
这个词的用法有点像，比如说蛮子这个词，
它是古代的北方人对南方边疆部族的一种灭称，
然后可能就出现了一类的建筑风格，
他们就拿来这个词，将这一类的建筑灌移，
比如说蛮子风。
用这个例子，就是大家可以明白到底是什么样的关系，
就是相当于借用一个心目中的野蛮的代名词，
来代表这种他们不喜欢的建筑风格。
那问题来了，就是什么样的风格特征的建筑，
让当时的文艺复兴的人文主义者不那么喜欢，
甚至要惯以野蛮的这种恶名呢。
这个就要从另一种建筑风格，罗曼士建筑，
说起罗曼士Romantic Architecture,。
也可以称作是罗马士，
它的特征是什么呢？
我这里说几个关键词，
比如说后中的墙体，小小的窗户，
半圆形的拱圈，
总之就是看起来非常敦实和沉重的这种感觉，
就是罗曼士建筑。
那么如果我说格特士建筑，
其实是对罗曼士建筑的一种突破，
那我们刚刚讲的那几种特征是如何突破的呢？
是不是就是墙体没那么后中了，
小小的窗户变得更大了，
而拱圈也不是半圆形的，
而变成了尖尖的了，
总之就是更轻盈，更鲜细。
到这里呢，
所以恭喜你，
现在你发明了格特士建筑。
所以这就有一个很有趣的事情啊，
就是说，
格特这个词现在一听啊，
总会让我们有一种对黑暗美学的这样一种想象，
比如说烟熏装呀，
黑色的衣服啊，
整个是非常阴暗，
而且神秘的。
但是听了刚刚我们对于他的这种描述，
其实我们会发现，
最开始格特士建筑的初衷啊，
其实正好相反。
就是这些轻盈的墙体，
尖尖的拱圈和大的花窗，
其实本质上都是在，
本质上是在追求光，追求明亮，
是阴暗的反面对吧，
和格特风这个词，
带给我们的这种黑暗意象，
其实是正好相反的。
那么我们接下来就从建筑结构的角度啊，
看看格特士建筑到底有什么特征，
格特士风格其实首先很好变人的，
首先第一个就是尖拱，
顾名思义就是尖尖的拱啊，
有点像瓜子的形状，
就与其对应的就是罗曼士建筑，
或者文艺复兴建筑中喜欢使用的这种拌原型的拱，
那么从历学上看呢，
尖拱可以通过调整拱的这个高度与跨度，
让拱顶的收离更加有力，
减少一部分的这个向外的这个侧向推力，
于是呢，建筑就有可能发展出更加纤细的沉重结构，
墙体也不必像罗曼士那样厚重，
这个就让运用了尖拱的建筑在视觉上有一种向上生疼的感受，
所以当我们站在格特士的教堂里就会发现，
视线是很容易被这些尖拱带向上方的，
就说建筑仿佛不再被牢牢的压在地面之上，
而是要不断的向天空生长，
甚至有一种想要脱离重力的感觉。
那说到这里，那是不是就和我们的魔法世界对应上了？
就我们人类对于魔法会有很多很多的想象，
而脱离地球重力绝对就是这些想象当中非常重要的一种，
比如说人可以骑着扫着飞起来，
然后物体可以悬在空中，
甚至作为建筑本身都可以似乎违背我们对于重量的一种直觉。
所以从这点来说呢，
电影选择格特士建筑作为霍格沃茨的主要场景语，
也是非常贴合哈利波特中的这个魔法世界的。
不过这里我还要特别说明一点，
就是在罗林的原著中，
其实并没有明确规定霍格沃茨是一座格特士的建筑。
所以我们今天看到的这些高耸的监拱，
花窗和塔罗琳利的霍格沃茨，
很大程度上是电影制作团队为这个魔法世界建立起来的一种视觉语言。
当然我觉得这个是一个非常优秀的一个二字创造。
另外说到监拱，
我还想补充一个格特建筑中比较有特征的东西就是花窗。
在哈利波特与火焰碑中，
哈利为了打开龙弹，
他来到了这个急涨的关系室，
里面有一个美人于画像的一个玻璃花窗。
这个场景虽然发生在一个非常魔法，
非常奇幻的空间里，
但它使用的其实是非常真实的一个中世纪的建筑语言。
那为什么会出现大面积的花窗，
竟然能够给花窗做出装饰的这些人像统案呢？
正是因为有了格特的监拱，
那它的受力更好了，
它有了骨架，对吧，
那墙体也就不再需要承担全部的巨大重量，
所以说墙面就可以出现相对比较大的窗户。
但是中世纪的时候，
还没有现代意义上的这种大尺寸玻璃，
所以巨大的窗洞并不能直接用一块玻璃封起来，
而是需要把那些小块的玻璃拼接起来，
然后再嵌入实质的这个窗领和框架之中，
最后就逐渐形成了非常有特征的这种格特式花窗。
这些花窗的图案越来越复杂，
有植物，有人物，有宗教故事等等。
那这其中最著名的，
大家都是知道的就是巴黎圣墓院的巨大的玫瑰窗。
那我们还是说回格特建筑的结构特征啊。
刚刚我们讲了肩拱，
那第二个特征就是肋拱顶，
是什么叫做肋拱呢？
肋骨的肋啊，
就顾名思义就是在一个拱顶上，
你能明显的看到一根根，
纤细的像肋骨一样的结构骨架，
而拱的其他部分就用很薄的这个材料作为添冲，
而其实在古罗马建筑，
罗马式建筑中也并不完全没有内功，
但是到了格特建筑，
它最大的变化在于，
原本隐藏在拱顶内部的结构线条，
越来越明确的表达成了一个，
非常清晰的一个骨架系统。
就我看到过一个很形象的比喻啊，
就是如果说把拱形的拱顶，
就是那种单方向连续的均匀的这种拱顶，
比如说是一整块厚厚的肥肉，
那么内拱顶就像是一根根排骨，
然后排骨之间呢用皮肉连着，
一个就是非常厚重，
另一个就很轻盈。
而这个比喻实在是太形象，
说到这里我都有点饿了。
那么话说回来，
格特式把原本隐藏在拱顶中的这个结构线条呢，
发展成了一套清晰可见的骨架系统，
而到了英国晚期的格特式呢，
内拱又进一步的发展，
它的数量越来越多，
较之成越来越复杂的继合网络，
所以内拱不再只是简单的承担和传递结构力量，
而开始同时成为空间中非常喜慕的一种视觉元素。
所以它成为了背心上的对象，
所以结构继合和装饰呢，
就最终融合在一起，
发展出了英国式格特，
最有特色的供订形式之一，
就叫做善行供订，
FanWalt,。
这其中最经典的，
就要数这个哈里伯特与密室的那个场景，
就是管理员菲尔吉的猫洛里斯夫人，
他被实话了，
然后墙上出现了密室已经被打开了的那个血资。
这个场景真是取景地呢，
就是英国的格洛斯特大教堂的回廊之中，
大家还记得我们刚才讲过回廊吧，
就是修道院建入里面，
围绕着一个方形庭院的一圈有顶的廊道，
那格洛斯特大教堂的这个回廊，
最著名的特征之一，
就是在这个大教堂里面，
这个回廊最著名的特征之一，
就是它的扇形公顶，
就是这些由柱子发出的这些扇形的内拱，
好像是一排一排巨大的扇，
或者说让整个空间仿佛笼罩在这层巨扇的这个底部。
那这个空间其实是非常漂亮的，
可惜电影中实在是太暗了，看不清楚，
我在收纳特中把真实的照片放过来，
大家可以看一下。
另外有一个场景是新生第一次来到霍格沃茨的时候，
就是麦格教授站在楼梯那里引荐学生。
这个场景的区境地是牛津大学的这个基督堂学院，
它的大厅的大楼梯。
这个楼梯上同样有一些非常漂亮的扇形公顶，
所以说扇形公顶某种程度上可以说是非常具有英国变势度的歌特诗语言，
就是它并不是所有地方的歌特都有的东西，
而是英国所独有的一种歌特的形式。
所以霍格沃茨的这种英式的味道，
就是通过这些非常小的一些建筑细节所建立起来的。
那么歌特建筑的第三个结构特征就是《飞浮碧》，
《Flying Butchers》。
《飞浮碧》的出现同样和歌特建筑师不断追求。
更高、更轻盈、更开放的建筑有关。
就是我们刚刚说过，拱顶会产生向外的侧向推力，对吧？
所以歌特建筑师就在建筑的外部设置了一系列的浮碧，
就把这些力量通过外部的结构支撑传递到地面，
然后帮助抵抗拱顶对强体产生的一种侧推力。
大家可以想象一下，就是伊犊本来快要向外倾倒的墙，
然后旁边突然伸过来一只巨大的手臂，把它牢牢浮住，
而这个手臂就是《飞浮碧》。
不过《飞浮碧》这个东西在哈里波特电影中并不是一个特别醒目的元素，
我猜可能是因为这种麻瓜式的这种工程式的建筑结构，
它并不适合表现魔法世界的这种奇幻感，
所以在这里我们就不多展开了。
那么综合以上，歌特式建筑用肩拱、拱类和《飞浮碧》这些结构上的力气，
共同构成了一种轻盈的向上仿佛症和重力的一种崇高的空间，
这也和哈里波特中所希望塑造的魔法世界不谋而合。
同样，歌特式的语言也让魔法和中世纪这两种东西产生了联系，
因为我们现在人想象魔法就很容易想到，
比如说中世纪、炼金树、宗教和一些古老的知识等等，
那么歌特式建筑正是中世纪最具有辨识度的一种建筑语言。
同时它又是一套真正存在的语言，就是我们之前已经在魔法世界观内一部分讨论过，
就是让一个东西产生魔法感，并不是要发明一套完全不存在的语言，
而是把真实存在的历史进行修改，比如说让它动起来，让它漂浮起来。
这也就解释了为什么哈里波特电影中要去英国那么多真实存在的中世纪建筑中取景。
就只有当魔法是从真实世界中衍生出来的时候，
这个魔法才会更具有力量。
另外，除了刚刚说的回廊的几个场景，
还有一些非常重要的场景的取景地，
我们可以在这里简单的说一下，
比如说大家最熟悉的霍国泽的大理堂，
它的原型就是牛津大学的基督教堂学院大厅，
但实际上电影并不是在牛津大学那时景拍摄的，
而是真的他们在片场改了一个大厅，
但是这个大厅的格局和布置明显参考了基督教堂学院大厅，
尤其是我们在第二部分讲的那个四条场桌和一条高桌的这种空间秩序，
都在电影中被非常明确地还原了。
那么霍国泽的图书馆的取景地，
是一个非常典型的十六世纪末学院中的隔间式图书馆。
这种图书馆并不是我们今天熟悉的那种一排一排书架紧密的排列，
然后读者自己进去拿书，
然后再出来在一个开放的桌面上去阅读这样的一种布局，
而是把书架和桌子都结合在一个小隔间里面。
同时它的书籍的保存取悦和阅读都有一套非常不同的制度。
那这种图书馆为什么会长这个样子，
然后这些书是怎么取出来的？
关于这些问题呢，还是推荐大家收听我们阿尔法城第三期图书馆建筑的历史。
上期在那里，我们已经做过比较详细的解读，
大家可以感兴趣可以听一下。
所以最后我们来总结一下后国自制作建筑，
它虽然是一座虚构的一个魔法城堡，
但它并不是一个凭空想象出来的东西。
它的基因中有城堡，有塔楼，有墙园，有这些神秘的垂直的空间，
也有修道院的回廊公共餐厅，也有英国技术制学校的宿舍，
公共休息室，学院制度。
这一切呢，最后呢，又都被戈特士的建筑语言统一在了一起。
那同时呢，哈里波特系列的电影中啊，
也并没有简单的只找一座古老的城堡，
把它说成是后国词。
而是它从英国的各个地方，各个角落，
借用了许多学院和宗教建筑的一些空间，
然后再通过镜头剪辑的方式，
把这些几百年的建筑空间统一和重组起来。
所以我们最后看到的后国词呢，虽然现实中是不存在这样一所唯一的城堡，
但是它又有一种非常强烈的真实感，
就是源于它身上的每一个部分都能够在现实世界中找到它的来源。
然后这种真实感也因此让，
处于麻瓜世界的我们对寂寞生又熟悉的这个魔法世界产生了非常强烈的效果。
那么今天呢，我们主要讲的是后国词。
而其实在哈里波特的世界中呢，
除了学校之外，还有许多其他的魔法建筑，
也体现了非常不一样的哲学和世界观。
举几个例子，比如说漏居，为什么长成那样。
然后对角像的房子为什么都是歪歪扭扭的。
但是马尔福家的这个庄园为什么又非常的堂皇和端正。
然后巫师世界的这个政府大楼，政府机关，又是怎样的。
等等一些细致末节的一些小问题。
本来想更全面的讲一讲，
但是目前时间已经大大超出了我的预期程度。
那么如果说大家想要继续听这个系列的话，
欢迎给我留言评论。
那今天的阿尔法程就到这里，我们下次再见，拜拜。